Ciao benvenuti in un nuovissimo video
Oggi parliamo
Di calcio in particolare delle ragazze e il calcio sì perché noi ragazze insomma ci dividiamo tra
chi lo ama e chi lo odia chi è bravissima a giocare a calcio e chi è proprio negata ecco
Ho deciso di raggruppare tutte queste tipologie in un video buona visione e da tanto che non. Gioco è il mio avviso
Proviamo a fare il tifo
No, no non mi sono fatto niente
O cosa stai facendo ecco la faccia amici ai parenti agli. Amici. Ma. Ce la fai da te fondamentale lira ma. È troppo bravo per
biondo
La partita lascia la partita
non puoi farlo ha preso la palla con le mani amorevoli del portiere lui può
ultimi ha deciso e cosa che sento mia la solita coloni e l'altra squadra quindi non, meno marina si chiama sostituzione
È però però con gli ha la maglietta in alto colore scusi perché lui può e gli altri alla maglia uguale
Amore ma quando finisce siamo al 23esimo. Ancora la 22 minuti ei suoi finora vinciamo
finisce il primo tempo
e poi e poi altri 45 questa squadra p
No vabbè ma stiamo scherzando
addormentano
Arrivare tutti e lui lo fa di sicuro
Mamma
sì stiamo dando alla partita
guardare la partita ha detto che arrivò
non abbiamo
Nov abbiamo ma quanto è buono il 4
A me aver usato il 10 di vino lì con le braccia
vabbè ma non dice che colpaccio a
Cioè che caldo
Ma va bene è sposato con successo. Dai no e stato veramente quello ma quelle single
Praticamente ribaltiamo subito
Cosa abbiamo detto è chi vinceva di vincere
Sportivo quelli che sanno perdere ma. Siamo, I migliori non c'è per nessuno per nessuno
Cioè adesso spiegatemi cosa c'è di bello vedere. I 25 c che corrono dietro. Una palla ma. Qui pagati per fare cosa
Ma. Guarda veramente e l'erba lei è battuta con
L'erba felpe statali inutilmente cioè perché perché perché siamo ora questa roba cioè io odio il calcio
andiamo
Ci siano ci siamo sta per arrivare
e andiamo
Bene che c'è da guardare non. Ha mai visto. Una ragazza giocare a calcio
È così purtroppo arrivati alla fine del video vi raccomando. Se il video vi è piaciuto
Lasciatemi un like e commentate qui sotto con o queste
Mozy o collage tag primo straining e soprattutto fatemi sapere a quale di queste tipologie
Appartenete voi se anche voi volete la porta che ho utilizzato nel video vi basterà comprare tre tubi di pringles avere inter iniziativa. Cliccare
Sul sito che vi lascio questo indiscrezione e seguire le istruzioni per partecipare anche voi al primo strani
Se la prima volta che vedete un mio video mi raccomando
Iscrivetevi al canale e cliccate sulla campanella ritrovate vicino al tasso d'iscrizione per rimanere sempre aggiornati, su tutti. I
Miei video e soprattutto per essere. I primi a commentare
Ultima cosa ma. Non per importanza seguitemi su tutti. I social instagram facebook e music hall mimando macedone ci vediamo al prossimo video
ciao